[Musique]
c'est le regard triste que le maire de
wieliczka contemple ce qui aurait dû
être un hôpital quasiment terminé
l'hôpital est censé être construits
juste ici derrière ce bâtiment là bas il
devrait y avoir un centre de
réhabilitation est ici un centre de
formation ce qui est en train d'être
construit ne représente qu'une petite
part de ce qui était prévu la ville
comptait sur le plan de relance européen
les autorités locales avaient demandé au
gouvernement d'en recevoir une partie
le ministre nous a écrit ceci bon projet
vous pouvez y aller mais depuis silence
radio
tout est en suspens est ce que le plan
de relance pour la pologne n'est pas
mise en oeuvre bien sûr cela est dû à la
question de l'état de droit et à la
rétention des fonds suite à l'arrêt de
la cour européenne
comme toutes les villes polonaises
wieliczka a largement bénéficié de fonds
européens
de l'argent qui a permis de financer des
bus une nouvelle gare une bibliothèque
et même la restauration de la mine de
sel de la ville une des raisons de cet
arrêt des financements est à chercher du
côté de la cour suprême polonaise en
2018 une nouvelle chambre disciplinaire
il a été créé son but juger des
magistrats accusées d'avoir agi
légalement nous soutenons l'appel du
ministre de la justice contre la
décision de la cour régionale et pour
juger ses juges on trouve des magistrats
nommés par le parti au pouvoir et qui
ont tendance à s'attaquer aux juges
opposés aux réformes une menace pour
l'impartialité selon la cour de justice
de l'union européenne qui a ordonné à la
pologne de suspendre les activités de la
chambre ou de payer un million d'euros
d'amendé par jour mais elle ne l'a pas
fait vous du chèche
aujourd'hui ils devaient examiner une
procédure contre vos dit me giroux ben
là le véritable leader morale et
symbolique de cette cour suprême
aujourd'hui ses avocats ont quelque
chose à fêter la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme a estimé que cette
audience ne devait pas avoir lieu jamais
auparavant la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme n'était allé aussi loin pour
statuer sur des affaires de ce type
normalement de telles mesures d'urgence
ne sont prises que dans des cas
exceptionnels par exemple lorsque la vie
ou la santé d'une personne est en danger
pour ses avocats militants c'est la
démocratie polonaise qui est en danger
si le gouvernement parvient à remodeler
la cour suprême comme ils le souhaitent
cela parachèvera l'instauration d'un
système autoritaire en pologne ce ne
sera plus une démocratie mais je pense
que les polonais voit maintenant que
nous sommes sur une trajectoire de
collision avec l'union européenne ne
serait ce que parce que l'argent du plan
de relance n'arrive toujours pas et il
considère que la position des juges qui
résiste aux réformes être héroïques et
représente surtout la dernière chance de
sauver le système judiciaire car nos
citoyens veulent faire partie de l'ue
mais le gouvernement polonais nie en
bloc l'existence d'un problème
quelconque tout comme le font les juges
pro-gouvernementaux nommé à la cour
suprême au losc à saint denis le pouvoir
judiciaire polonais s'efforce toujours
d'appliquer la loi et de respecter les
normes constitutionnelles et donc
également les normes européennes
pour alexander slafkovsky les juges
rebelles est serré simplement de
préserver leur propre pouvoir et les
institutions européennes
critique des réformes judiciaires serait
remplie d'amis de ses juges rebelles
polonais
lorsqu'un ami vous appelle d'un autre
pays pour vous dire qu'on lui a fait du
tort vous avez tendance à le croire
à ma connaissance lors de l'examen de
plaintes concernant le système
judiciaire polonais il ne me semble pas
qu'une institution étrangère et demandé
à la cour suprême de vérifier ces
accusations
donc vous mettez en doute le
professionnalisme de ces personnes oui
ce juge de la cour suprême aurait dû
passer devant la chambre disciplinaire
la semaine dernière vaut au jimmy'z
vroubel ne connaît que trop bien le
portrait que font les autorités des
juges rebelles une sorte de caste qui
défend ses propres intérêts ce n'est
aucunement dans notre intérêt personnel
de risquer de perdre la moitié de nos
salaires d'être suspendu est interdite
d'audience de devenir un ennemi public
est un objet de haine pour la propagande
d'état
mais selon lui c'est une question
d'éthique professionnelle que de
respecter la loi plutôt que d'accepter
des réformes qui la viole et s'éteint
voir envers les autres européens que
d'en parler
les principes de l'état de droit doivent
être commun à tous c'est pourquoi nous
ne pouvons pas tolérer cela il faut
faire attention au tard cet
autoritarisme pourrait venir frapper à
la porte du portugal de l'espagne ou de
tout autre pays le juge grübel a étudié
et enseigne aujourd'hui à l'université
de jaj l'aune de cracovie un bastion de
la pensée libérale pendant l'ère
communiste des idées qui ont triomphé en
1989 lorsque la démocratie est revenu en
pologne
nous avons eu une expérience si brève de
la démocratie donc même si je parle
d'état autoritaire je pense toujours que
ce qui se passe maintenant est une sorte
de crise d'adolescence comme ce moment
où l'adolescent doit passer par une
phase sauvage pour devenir ensuite un
adulte à part entière
le même jour à cracovie des magistrats
et des sympathisants manifestent contre
la suspension d'une autre juge
protestataires les affaires qu'elle
jugeait sont maintenant à l'arrêt tout
comme les milliards d'euros de fonds
européens destinés à la pologne